all right let's do some audience
questions this week's questions are
really good first one is from Li Li says
do you have a frightening childhood
experience that that has affected you
into adulthood there's one in particular
that I can think of which is I generally
don't like medical stuff I don't like
videos of medical procedures I don't
like any of it and I remember being
seven or eight years old and walking by
the living room and this was when TLC
The Learning Channel I don't know if
they used to be the Learning Channel now
it's just TLC or vice versa anyway that
channel now it's a lot of reality shows
and like house programs and stuff like
that it used to be they used to show
medical procedures and surgeries and
once my dad was watching some kind of
eye procedures and eye surgery and it
freaked me out so bad that I remember
getting very nauseous and it wasn't
something I was supposed to see I just
kind of walked by I think it was later
at night I came out of my room or
something like that and when I think
about I don't know if that was actually
the catalyst when I think about now my
just disc distaste for any medical stuff
and just anxiety around medical issues
and stuff like that
I think back to that and I think back to
visiting my grandfather in the hospital
after he had had a relatively minor
heart attack from what I recall and just
really hating the whole vibe and I know
most people probably don't like
hospitals or medical facilities but I
think that for me it's something that
has really affected me as an adult still
I've actually undergone two pre major
surgeries and I've offered to show you
the video clips for them in the past but
you're just not willing to see them
there they're not even that invasive I
have no interest in that do you want to
say what the procedures were not so much
okay all right well we'll talk about
that later
okay so yeah I mean that I certainly
remember that another one that I sort of
remember is when I got to the United
States and going to school and I didn't
speak any English so I I couldn't
understand what anybody was saying and I
think that although now I'm perfectly
comfortable traveling to countries where
I don't understand the language and I
sort of find it interesting to spend
three months on duolingo a rosetta stone
trying to get some understanding of a
new language I still remember
the sort of feeling of not knowing what
the hell is going on which for me in
great part was because I didn't speak
the language well I think now you're
just in a very good position knowing
both English and Spanish because those
are both very international languages
that if people aren't native speakers of
they may have that as their second
language so sure in a very good position
especially to go to places like Europe
yeah I mean and not only that because
even people who don't speak English in
Europe if you go to Italy or France or
Portugal you're going to have a very
easy time if you speak Spanish fluently
in at minimum figuring out what the
signs say and having you know basic
conversation particularly in Italy and
Portugal yeah and if that doesn't work
you can always resort to drawing
pictures or something else yeah I
actually have friends who when they went
to China they got drawings not not
drawings characters Chinese characters
so that they could hold them up to
communicate certain things like they
were vegetarian so they had signs which
were like I am vegetarian please bear in
mind that even if you give me just
vegetables it might be cooked in meat
broth and the meat broth makes it not
vegetarian which ended up being super
useful because they would go to a lot of
restaurants and were it not for the
clarification in Chinese characters that
somebody wrote up for them they would
have been in a real trouble you know
when I was in Portugal I tried to go to
this breakfast place and tried to order
eggs because it was a few years ago
before I was vegan and all else and so
first I used the English word hoping
they would know the word eggs didn't
work then I moved on to the Spanish word
thinking you know they're right next to
Spain Davos they should be able to
understand that yeah also didn't work I
just left the place that wasn't gonna
deal with yeah there's another thing
which is that I've been told that for
historical reasons in Portugal they
don't like it when you try to speak in
Spanish to them so when I went there
even though I knew we could easily
communicate if I spoke Spanish and they
spoke Portuguese when I couldn't
communicate in Portuguese I would just
speak English because I was told that's
sort of considered off-putting if you
look at a map of which states are more
bilingual in Europe it's really not
places like Portugal or Spain or England
or Scotland it's more of a central part
of Europe yeah all right well in any
case those are my thoughts on that